I guess the strategy I would impart for
using the web is develop a core of
websites that you think are useful and
really rely on those rather than
starting every day with the entire world
wide web and seeing what's interesting
because you know that's a great way to
waste a day and God knows I've done it
but if you sort of order your your day
you know if you if you have a fixed
group that you feel confident you'll get
a decent grounding in they will link you
to other stuff that's that's interesting
but rather than just sort of wandering
around in the in the in the gray digital
wilderness I think it's better to have 5
10 websites that you sort of breeze
through every day and at that point you
can feel like you're pretty much current
and if you want to explore further fine
but use the ones that you trust to allow
you to do the rest of your job
I don't think so I mean I guess my
questions about my questions about
vlogging are really more ID my questions
about blogging are really more economic
than journalistic I think there are a
lot of great blogs out there and and I
certainly read them the problem in
journalism now is how are we going to
finance news gathering how are we going
to finance the people who go to Iraq
that who collect the information that
bloggers then comment on in the New York
Times business model it appears to me is
in the verge of falling apart in the New
York Times has 60 people in Baghdad we
are all dependent on those 60 people to
comment on the on journalism so you know
bloggers are great at pointing out the
foibles of other journalists they are
great at analyzing news but they are not
great at collecting and going out and
getting news and what I am concerned
about as a citizen and also as a
journalist is that there be journalistic
institutions that have the money to send
people to Baghdad and have the money to
pay bloggers for health insurance you
know I I just think the model that says
people are just so obsessed with the
news they'll blog from there they're in
their bathrobes and on their sofas you
know there are going to be eccentric
people like that but I think in order to
have a informed citizenry we have to
have journalistic institutions in place
whether they be bloggers or newspapers
or magazines or television networks that
pay for news gathering and that doesn't
seem like a sure thing to me now and
that's what I'm concerned
I think CNN is in a heck of a lot better
shape to face the changing technological
future then say any newspaper I can
think of because you know we do appear
to be approaching in a way that I can't
came we do appear to be approaching a
moment where the institution of the
computer and the institution of the
television set are starting to merge
together and you know I find that I am
watching stuff on my computer much more
than I used to live or you know close to
live and certainly management at CNN is
is encouraging us to view you know our
content dispersal function as one that
you know crosses platforms seamlessly
and I think the CNN brand and what makes
CNN good is very transferable to the web
and people are working on how to do that
now I don't claim to be an expert on on
how to do that but I just think it's not
a great leap to see how the C&A you know
our CNN function will move more or less
seamlessly from the web to cable
television now I think the economics are
complicated because you know as the
cliche goes your trading you know
internet dollars for internet pennies
and so the advertising model and the
subscription model that we have is a
heck of a lot more profitable still on
regular cable television that it is on
the web but I think CNN is well
positioned to you know work both
simultaneously I think it's much harder
for print
I in general don't make the mistake of
confusing my own journalistic interests
with the world's journalistic interests
at The New Yorker I like reading the
early versions of my colleague stories
before they run in the magazine because
they tend to be longer because I like
long stories now every survey you see
out there says people want shorter
stories so fine I just you know I don't
feel like I'm obligated to agree with
everyone else out there I like reading
along magazine articles and I think it's
great that there is one magazine
essentially the new yorker that does
this on on a regular and sustained basis
and fortunately there seemed to be a
substantial number of readers out there
who are willing to pay for it but so
what do I think is missing let me you
know i guess to what i think is missing
is more in-depth journalism you know
more long-form examination of people and
issues you know everybody's trying to
come up with you know the website that
gets you the most information in the
shortest period of time and i understand
that that's a valuable thing i think
there are a lot of people trying to do
the same thing I wish there were a lot
of people trying to write a
thousand-word stories there doesn't
appear to be a lot of demand for it but
I have I demand